gamespot has put together swipe our
first ever mobile game showcase it's
happening on september 8th and will be
hosted by greg miller from kind of funny
who promises he will keep his shirt on
while sharing new and exclusive details
about the platform in everyone's pocket
praise be to jesus and
joining him will be me tamor hussein and
kurt indovina with interviews from
gamespot's mobile gaming editor kyle
hilliard along with those interviews you
can expect new trailers and updates for
games like ubisoft's the division
resurgence cookie run kingdom and pubg
mobile you'll also be able to see which
of your favorite games are coming to
mobile check out some upcoming indie
experiences and even hear from
activision's call of duty team we'll
also have details about new games from
netflix as well as what's up next for
apple arcade the livestream event will
put the spotlight on the latest and
greatest games for ios and android
devices make sure to tune in september
8th at 10am pt on youtube.com forward
slash gamespot or twitch.tv forward
slash gamespot to watch the first ever
swipe showcase see you then